the jurogan experience i was nervous
when people when friends say i got a new
show you're like oh i gotta watch this
[ __ ] because so many times you watch
your friend's show and it's not good
your show is [ __ ] good it's a real
solid sitcom so thank you thank you and
right out of the gate it's solid you
know sitcoms take
years to get their legs at least a few
episodes but right out of the gate your
show is very solid i wish you knew how
hard it was for me to text you to ask
you to watch it i'll text i
typed the text and i was like oh i can't
because i know how honest you are and
then when i was like i it took me months
and i was like but i gotta ask him
because i was like if joe liked it then
i feel like you you it was it was a seal
a solid foundation and i'm like if i
could just cause i got aura to watch it
he's like he's really good and i was
like i just want to see if joe will
watch it and i know how [ __ ] busy you
are and i kept when i sent the text and
i was like oh my god oh my god he's not
gonna watch it out and when i hit you
back hey and he was like i'm in the
middle of uranium whatever the [ __ ] that
word you use you somewhere for what
birds don't have wings but they still
fly you was on vacation
where was i somewhere rich people go
birds don't have wings but they still
fly what kind of riddle is this
what the [ __ ] it's called a crackhead
that's a solving riddle
birds don't have wings they still fly i
just
that's what you [ __ ] say i can't
i'm heavily placed i could oh okay i was
on vacation he was on vacation i think
he said he was in the meadow i'm [ __ ]
up the verge uh probably the caribbean
uh i started with an m m
i don't [ __ ] know
i was so probably i don't you it was
texting so when when you started to text
me like what you the jokes in the show
you don't know how much air went out of
my titties that day joe
it's a good show i'm very happy it's a
good show very happy it's it's rock
solid it really is
we worked our ass out this year
it was so hard with a comedy because to
me comedy is so rehashed and i feel like
hollywood is so out of ideal that's why
we getting all these [ __ ] reboots
that even with the pilot we went through
the hand and told to make sure you
haven't heard it original jokes original
jokes a lot of it is my stand up and so
that was another thing i was like should
i send you this oh his auntie's a pit
and i asked you for your honest opinion
you was like oh pet i really don't want
to watch it because i don't like
watching my friends i said just watch
the [ __ ] you can't hurt my family i've
been shot i've had gonorrhea i've been
hit by a freak [ __ ] thing give it to
me joe like hard dick with no condom and
so you you text back and i immediately
text him say look what [ __ ] joe rogan
said
i can't the n word
cause your [ __ ] podcast is so big i'm
oh she said that it ran off again [ __ ]
you but
um even said it in the past on here well
i i
said [ __ ] look what john
i said wake your black ass up [ __ ] joe
roger like our show
and like i said it takes a while like
when when i did news radio that was in
the 90s it took like
four or five episodes before the show
really started finding its way yeah it
takes a while it does it does i like for
for i i first saw pat like maybe i was a
senior in high school i'm 26 now i was a
senior in high school my dad had
recorded her on this daytime talk show
and he was like you got to watch it
sonic james she's yes harry kind of
jerry comic cheese i remember that show
you're on that show yes yep and she my
dad was like you got to watch her like
she's hilarious like you're a lover you
love her and so i sat down and watched
and i just fell in love because i like
to do the type of comedy where it's like
you laugh over the pain you laugh over
it you laugh through it and that's her
life
that's her brand and so i was like damn
like whenever she gets a book i'm going
to read that damn book like i'm going to
study it that's going to be my [ __ ] then
i got to college book came out it was
like 35 i couldn't afford it so i
screenshot it i was like i'm going to
come back and get this booker and i get
some money
never was able to get the book but i
wrote this play called ain't no mode
that went to the public in new york
what's it girl uh it was called ain't no
mo uh and it was at the public theater
and uh lee daniel saw it and after he
saw it he was like hey
uh we're trying to do a tv show for this
uh comedian her name is miss pat but we
don't really have a concept nobody
really knows what they want to do so can
you just read her book and see if you
can come up with a concept for a show
and i was just happy to get the damn
book but i read it and i just fell in
love and i immediately saw this sitcom
in my head because i'm a big fan of like
old school sitcoms like all in the
family the jefferson's good times with a
live studio audience and i just felt
like putting like her in this dollhouse
of a sitcom and just burning all of it
down damn son
god damn you're talking with your hands
goddamn jump rope
that's how i talk
i'm a homosexual we talk with our hands
dick
i'm learning so much today birds who fly
with their wings
yes
put your hands down
for you to be 26 and to create a show is
pretty [ __ ] amazing it was a ride
because listen when lee first came
brought me brought this kid to me and uh
i'm honest and i know hollywood is full
of [ __ ] and it's so hard to get people
in the industry not to sound like a
talking [ __ ] ted everybody said the
same goddamn thing and i was just i have
to break them down either you be honest
with me or i don't [ __ ] with you so when
i met him and lee was like oh i got this
kid he fell out of heaven and da da da
and i'm like okay lee and he told me i'm
in i'm in [ __ ] utah someone performed
he said get your ass on the plane you
got to go see the players that last
night i said uh i don't know if you know
how this [ __ ] worked but i'm a comedian
i'll get paid tomorrow and i ain't going
no god damn well i need my little
pennies okay so they put me on a plane i
flew over to watch him and i pick up me
i deal with people with spirits your
energy i can just tell if you're a good
person i can tell when [ __ ] is gonna
happen and when i met him i said he
could do it and the first thing i did i
called him and i said they're never
gonna give you this job he said police
say they're gonna hire me i said no
they're not he said why you say that i
said because you ain't never did [ __ ]
and they don't understand p hollywood
want what everybody else is wanting they
don't want you until somebody else don't
[ __ ] you and brush your booty i mean
check that out take it out
no keep it in there keep it in there
now he got all kind of interviews but i
saw him down and i said that you're
gonna hear they're gonna take you to
fancy dinners and try to blow your
[ __ ] mind i said if you listen to a
real [ __ ] like me we can do this i said
now i'm gonna be honest with you lee is
busting his ass
to get this job for you i said but while
lee is busting his ass to get you this
job let me show you how to get this job
he said what i got to do i said let's
write a pilot behind me [ __ ]
back and i started to tell him what the
other two writers want to listen to me
on and he listened and we wrote that
[ __ ] by eight days so when we
finished it i said he put his name on it
i said take your [ __ ] name my foot
which i was like what
[ __ ]
because
everything for me comes from the
knowledge that i got from streets okay
you can never outsmart me because i'm
[ __ ] you might get spell a word right
but [ __ ] i got google and two
daughters with a college degree so i get
your ass back on that too so i told him
i said take your name off but he's like
why i said because if they don't like it
they're not going to give you the
[ __ ] job but if i tell them i did it
i'm the star of the show they're going
to oh mr throw that [ __ ] in the trash
can we're gonna get you a writer so what
we did he took his name off i said well
you said one thing you ain't never got
to worry about me doing is stealing [ __ ]
from you i i'm not that type of person i
said what the [ __ ] i look like stealing
[ __ ] these people know i can't spell all
this [ __ ] correctly
that's exactly and that's exactly what
she did she called lee and she sent it
to lee and lee car and said
who the [ __ ] wrote this and she said she
said me he said no you didn't [ __ ]
because everything smelled right
and that's when i said me and jordan
wrote and you want to hear something so
crazy so this kid just graduated college
right and lee was like just drop out of
college you're gonna be a fan writer
don't you drop out of [ __ ] college so
i asked myself do you have found a draft
he was like no he's poor as [ __ ] he said
i don't have to find a drug i said [ __ ]
take my credit card take my debit card
go buy you some groceries and buy final
draft oh i imagine had me interviewing
writer's joe me and him i said yup right
[ __ ] right they got me another
interview right [ __ ] right
yeah
but like what's funny though
is that like she she like it was it was
something i was talking about this
yesterday i was like it takes a lot to
earn pat's trust in that sense because
she was literally it was like she was
entrusting me with her comedy and her
story and so like it was funny where
like i would write a draft or something
and i would send it i would send it over
to her and she read it she'd be like
[ __ ] why you got me cussing i said
but
because that's how you talk she said
[ __ ] i don't my [ __ ] talk like that
take that [ __ ] out
that's how you talk and i was like we
have to do a new kind of sitcom i wanted
to do something where it's like you
could just be yourself you know because
you look at all those old shows you look
at stanford and someone red fox or even
the richard pryor show that he had for
like three seconds and it's like imagine
if he was just allowed to be himself
right that show would last forever
red fox got as close as you can get on
the network television show to be in red
fox yup exactly that's exactly what you
can get exactly but they don't do those
anymore they're scared and when he came
to me and he said well actually after we
wrote the pilot they immediately gave
him a job after we wrote the pile they
was like this kid can write and i told
him i said see i know the [ __ ] i'm
talking about because hollywood is so
stripped they scared to step outside the
box they're gonna give you the same old
[ __ ] we need a black writer well
that black writer might not understand
what the [ __ ] miss pat trying to do and
i went through a few that did not
understand what i was trying to do with
him we we i took him and i said if you
just listen we can create something just
listen to these stories i just need you
to put the [ __ ] in the right form and he
did and he got the [ __ ] job watch the
entire episode for free only on spotify